are you prepared to do what must be
done i hope you're right about this
organism
haven't i been right so far the
microchip we've implanted in your brain
is working flawlessly
if you get into any trouble down there
we will be able to communicate
now hurry and go we haven't much time
activate teleport activating
multi-dimensional teleportation brace
for dematerialization
this will be the end of you once and for
all and with luck
the rest of your pathetic species as
well
ship docking in bay 4.
incoming life form status unarmed
i have just folded space from blicks the
blixonians were not happy about the new
taxation laws you imposed upon them
the blixonians are never happy but they
will
obey me they wouldn't want to be a
repeat of the trollion empire
remember they defied me
how many trollion organisms are around
today
only me exactly
i hope you enjoyed your first mission
without me because now it's back to
regular duties
i need my circuit board indexed yes
quinn sire
what are you working on if you don't
mind me asking i haven't decided yet but
i'm thinking about reviewing star wars
the force awakens
garbage did you ask me i didn't ask for
your opinion get to work
and i think star wars the force awakens
is a good idea actually
computer activate teleport and change my
clothes
materializing clothes all right so it's
happened i finally watched
all of the star wars movies and
it's been a wild ride so i recently
watched
all three of the disney star wars movies
and in this video i will be reviewing
star wars
the force awakens this movie was
pretty well made i have to say i mean it
basically hit all the same
plot points of a new hope it basically
just redid all of that stuff
but i guess in a fun way to where if i
was a star wars fan
and i had seen a new hope as a kid and
i've grown up on star wars
i would have probably liked this movie
although it doesn't do anything
particularly innovative with you know
the star wars universe or the plot
um it kind of just brings back the
characters together and they're just
hanging out introduces new characters
that basically do
essentially the same thing that other
characters have done in the past
they basically took their old characters
kind of like remixed them into these new
characters because you got like
rey who is basically luke skywalker
so she's on a desert planet that's not
tatooine
and also not arrakis it's called jakku
and it's it's essentially a mix around
of luke's story so you have in the
beginning of this movie
you got you got the the empire they're
looking no wait excuse me excuse me
not the empire they're not the empire
it's the first order i don't really
understand
why things are the way they are i don't
know the history of how
how it's now the first order but
whatever it's the first order
and they're doing the same thing that
the empire was doing they're basically
the empire renamed
and they're looking for a droid and this
droid's got got
not the plans to destroy the death star
because there is no death star
there's death planet but we'll get to
that in a second it's got the plans
to got the map to luke skywalker
and you know they really really want it
and so you got kylo ren
and this guy's this guy's bad news he's
he's the new
darth vader and he's all like i gotta
get this map
and so but they can't get the map
because the droid's been sent off
by you know this guy who's kind of like
han solo but
then not poe dameron he's he's like a
han solo
luke skywalker rogue character
mix-up entanglement thing that works for
the resistance
so he puts he puts the map in the droid
and the droid's sent
off and he's in the desert and i've
never seen this plot before it's totally
new
anyway it makes its way to this girl ray
so ray ray's been hanging out on this
planet jakku
and she she totally doesn't like it
there but she's still there because she
feels like her parents are gonna come
back and i'm like just
just get over it ray whatever but anyway
the joy comes to her and for some reason
rey unlike most
people in the star wars universe for
some reason rey
actually cares about the droid and she's
like oh
i i'm gonna stop this droid from being
taken apart by this guy
i i honestly do considering the rest of
the star wars universe i have no idea
why rey is it like if you're gonna if
you're gonna if you're gonna save this
droid from
being captured and taken apart by this
guy
like wouldn't you want the droid so that
you could
use it because in a new hope
when luke gets r2d2 it's not because
like they're getting like
these droids because like they they want
to save the droids they're buying the
droids because they can use the droids
so i don't understand why rey is like oh
i'm gonna save this droid as though it's
like a little
animal i mean personally i think that
droids are definitely sentient in the
star
wars universe but like i don't know it's
kind of it's it's weird the way they
handle that sometimes
anyway moving on the world the life on
jakku
is pretty messed up for rey so she
essentially has to like go scavenging
and like big derelict ships looks like
something that you find in no man's sky
uh she scavenges parts and um she
collects all the stuff and she goes and
sells it
for like little i guess for nutrients
essentially
so that's basically what she does with
her life until this droid gets here
um and rewind rewind back back to the
droid's owner guy the han solo wannabe
guy poe dameron
uh so this guy is with the resistance
and you know kylo ren's chasing him down
and he's he's in this village
with with the map and kylo ren comes
there and they kill all the villager
peoples
and and and this guy gets taken prisoner
but then there's this one storm trooper
guy
who who's who's not uh not bad
anymore now i know that there's like
this whole thing with the stormtroopers
they've got like history and these
aren't exactly the same stormtroopers
from the other star wars stuff these are
the
first order troopers which is is
different somehow but
they're not really different they're
exactly the same they have the exact
same uniforms but it's like
i guess they're basically the same
anyway except he's not the same
and he kind of has a conscience and he
doesn't shoot these people so
later on when he's on the ship
he he he decides to help this poe
dameron guy escape
they steal a ship from the first order
and then they're like out of there
and so that's how they end up crash
landing on jakku
and so this guy this stormtrooper guy
who's now named
finn because his name was like f in
summon another number or whatever
so his name is finn now and he's on the
planet he thinks the posed guy is dead
he puts on his jacket and he ends up
finding
he runs into ray and the droid at the
whole
marketplace whatever and so she thinks
he's part of the resistance
and so that's how their thing gets going
so now they're on the run together
and people are after them and they're
after the droid and they end up
finding the millennium falcon so this
is one of the first things that i
noticed about this movie and
it is basically to be expected this
movie
to reiterate if i had watched the if i
had been a star wars person my whole
life
and i was just super into star wars and
i was just super excited about seeing a
new star wars movie
i would have seen this movie it and
probably liked it when i saw it in
theaters and you know
had fun watching it and i had fun
watching it this time but this movie is
basically 100 fan service so like
they they they they go to a ship and
then the ship is the millennium falcon
of course the most famous ship
in start in star wars one of the most
famous ships in science fiction
so they're on the millennium falcon and
they end up getting pulled into
i guess han solos the after after they
escape the
okay so first they have to have this
ridiculous chase scene but you know all
the
all the chase scenes all the
flying ships in movies and in tv shows
almost always it's ridiculous [ __ ]
so this is just another
ridiculous [ __ ] chase scene and ray
is really good at
piloting the ship i guess it's a
combination of her
taking apart derelict ships her entire
life so she knows how they work and then
also just like
the force you know what don't don't
complain to me about the force being
vague in this movie
the force has always been vague [ __ ]
so i don't give a [ __ ] so whatever using
the force in piloting ship so they
escape the guys
and they end up with han solo so now now
we got we got
it's taken on a different level because
they're with han solo they
go through some more [ __ ] with some
smuggler people han solo's always like
got some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
with smugglers he's always like screwing
somebody over and owing some people
money it's just like in
a new hope when like jabba the hutts
after him so they got it's like multiple
bands of smugglers like have issues with
hanzo
like [ __ ] you dude we want our money or
whatever the [ __ ] they want so
anyway they get away from those guys on
the millennium falcon and
they tell han solo about this map to
luke skywalker
and luke's and han solo at this point
totally
buys into the whole thing about the jedi
and the force
and one thing that this movie is making
clear that i feel like the other movies
don't really make too clear is that
the idea of like jedi and their magic
you know there's people that know about
it but it's not just like
everyone in the universe knows about the
jedi and what they can do it's more like
legend and myth so this movie really
tries to
build the idea that there's the myth
of the jedi and it's not it it's it's
is it real is it not but we got han solo
finally totally he fully believes in it
and he's seen it and he
so when they tell him that they got the
map to luke skywalker he's in
so they end up going to this other
planet
to meet the new version of yoda you know
i
like i said like i said it it's hidden
all the same beats as the older movies
especially new hope i know yoda doesn't
show up to empire strikes back but still
this is basically the new yoda
uh i can't remember her name but the big
head alien
the big eyes um that character kind of
sucked
totally just like kind of cliche i am
the old wise alien
here's a lightsaber let me tell all the
characters some
wise stuff about whatever anyway the new
death star is being built and it's like
giant and it's like a
giant death star and so the first order
which is basically the empire they just
want to destroy planets because like
just like how in a new hope the empire
just destroys planets for no reason
you got the first order that just they
just destroy planets for no reason
i don't understand really the benefit
of destroying planets
entire planets i mean there's resources
on those planets you don't know who's on
the planet i mean
the idea that we're just going to
destroy a bunch of planets it's just
like whatever i don't
whatever but anyway they destroyed a
bunch of planets so like things are more
dire so
so anyway back on the planet with the
yoda [ __ ] the the first order starts
attacking
and you know they're all like right and
they're like attacking and the
resistance comes and they help fight
and you know it's i have to say that
it's
a really well done scene and that's one
thing i have to point i i will say about
this movie is that
all of the action is just top-notch
the visual effects are top-notch it
seems like there's like a blending
of practical effects and cgi and a lot
of people said that there was
a lot of practical effects in the
prequels but like
i can't tell it all still looks bad here
practical effects look good the cgi
looks good everything looks phenomenal
the universe looks real
it just star wars universe looks realer
than it ever looked
so i have to like commend them for that
and doing such a good job on the visuals
for this movie
so it's beautiful battle sequence
reagan's capture and then and then kylo
ren's like i'm gonna take you to my
giant death star
starkiller base and so he takes her
there and so the resistance is like oh
no
like what do we do and then finn's all
like we gotta go
save her and and they're like oh if
we're gonna go save her then we gotta
we gotta destroy the the the starkiller
base so
we got like i said a new hope part two
instead of destroying their tiny little
death star
they're destroying the huge starkiller
base and they even do like a scene
where they have a size comparison they
were like no the death star was this big
starkiller base is like this big it's
like we're doing the same movie
basically
but everything's just bigger and more
exciting
and more you know a lot more stuff going
on but
it's more moving parts essentially but
it's basically the same story
um so you got you got han solo you got
finn and you got chewie they're all on
starkiller base
uh you got uh kylo ren which at this
point he's been revealed
to be han solo son ben solo
so he's han and leia's son and also yeah
princess leia is in this movie
i haven't mentioned her at all so
princess leia is in this movie and yeah
one thing about princess leia is that
like i just
she's been leading a rebellion for like
i don't know decades
why is she like so sweet and cuddly i
feel like after all this time
princess leia should have a little bit
more grit i would have liked to see
princess leia be kind of an
[ __ ] you know and she's kind of just
too sweet
and nice i mean she's been running
things since basically the beginning
she's
this is the woman that you know
strangled jabba the hutt to death
um so yeah i wish she could have done
more badassery i felt like she kind of
took
a sideline in this movie which i guess
is okay because they are kind of trying
to pass the torch to new characters
um but you know if you're gonna bring by
princess leia then you know give me
give me a little bit more i don't just
need her to be like
han solo and princess leia oh we used to
love each other but now we don't and
that's also another point i felt like
han solo
and princess leia's relationship
happened
totally freaking off screen so you got a
new hope they're bickering the whole
movie
and then you know empire strikes back
you know han solo gets frozen and then
they'll reunite it and return to the
jedi but then
they don't really get together until the
end of the movie when he realizes that
luke is her brother and she
she wants him and not luke and then you
know it skips
decades and you know their whole entire
relationship happened like
off screen which is kind of lame because
you get to this movie and then they're
like
separated again and i'm just like oh
whatever
anyway so back to back to starkiller
base let's see what the the gang is up
to
so you got rey she's she's strong in the
force right she's she's super strong in
the force and there's
there's even a scene with this guy snoke
right who is a repeat of palpatine
because you know we have that scene and
i think empire strikes back where we see
like the big
palpatine head it's super iconic so they
had to do that again we got that moment
again except with like giant snoke
um so he's like there's been an
awakening in the force have you felt it
um it's kind of ambiguous what that
means and i've seen all the movies at
this point and i
don't think they knew what they meant i
think they just had that there
just because we can do something with it
it sounds interesting
and they wake awakening in the force
whatever it means can mean whatever
whatever anyways rey is like super
powerful
she she gets this stormtrooper guy to
like let her go
and she's like she overcomes kylo ren
even she she you know gets into his mind
reminded me of that scene from harry
potter where you know harry potter turns
snape's mind spell back on him but not
kind of like that but not really because
she likes she's like
doing the jedi mind trick it's like he
will never be as strong as darth vader
is your fear so that's kind of that was
cool anyway
so she escapes so by the time that finn
and them are coming to rescue her
you know she's already out and then
they're all together and you get in
together
but then han solo i guess feels the
force
i don't know it's ambiguous and kylo ren
is also feeling the forces ambiguous
so they're kind of drawn together and so
star wars
loves loves loves to do this thing
where people are like standing in like a
giant
dome and there's like just like a tiny
little walkway
and no railings so star wars i don't who
designs
things like this where it's like you
could sneeze
and trip and like just totally fall over
the side
anyway so when i watched this the first
time
my initial thought was like well
somebody's about to [ __ ] die
like it's just like any time they do
anyway so you have to you have this
moment where where kylo
and han you know they're talking you
know you gotta you got
pawn he wants to bring him to the good
side you know you've got really good
lighting in this scene he's like half
dark and half light um so you can
you one thing about kylo ren too is that
this character is all about this
internal struggle dark and light
and then he's also battling like can i
live up to darth vader am i gonna be in
the shadow of darth vader
and that's also something that i think
that the filmmakers had in mind
when they were creating this character
and when they were making this movie in
particular because like the shadow of
darth vader is all over this movie
and the shadow of you know the original
movies is
all over this movie so of course that
shadow is being cast on the calorie and
he's afraid that he can never be good
enough
in a way i feel like that is the
filmmakers you know sp
talking about the fans you know
preparing to be judged by the fandom for
making this movie and to
dare think that they can create new
characters that can live up to old ones
so anyway kylo ren and his dad are
standing on this
this tiny little walkway in the middle
of nothing and han is trying to bring
him to the good side
and kylo ren's like you know what
no thank you and then he like totally
kills his dad and everyone freaks out
death of han solo it's super sad so kylo
ren has chosen
his side and then i guess in the climax
of the movie
we have to have a moment between rey and
kylo first
finn picks up the lightsaber and that's
a cool moment but of course like kylo
ren is like
way too badass for finn and i say of
course
but like because finn doesn't have any
training
but like ray also doesn't have any
training she and she's
really really good so at first so so
first like i said
finn is trying to fight kylo finn's no
match for kylo and then
rey calls the lightsaber to her
it's luke skywalker's lightsaber that
she got from the
the alien lady that wants to be yoda she
gets the lightsaber she calls it and
then she starts fighting kylo ren and
she's like ah
they're fighting and as they're fighting
the starkiller base is also falling
apart because they set up bombs and you
know you got the resistance attacking
so this is a really cool scene visually
so yeah totally the world falling apart
having this lightsaber battle
that looks rough it looks like a
struggle in fact i should make a comment
about the lightsaber battles
in all three trilogies because they're
different in every single trilogy
the lightsaber battle in the first
trilogy is kind of primitive the best
one i think is luke skywalker
versus darth vader in return of the jedi
but they're still kind of primitive
and then in the prequels the lightsaber
battles are more like
graceful dances it's like it's like
you've got four sensitive people sensing
each other's moves as they battle so
it's kind of like a dance it's very
graceful
very choreographed and here it's
different again these
feel more intense they feel
grittier um it's not
like a dance it's more like a struggle
so i definitely was kind of like biting
my nails watching the lightsaber battle
because it was intense
and so the world's falling apart so they
end up
rey ends up overcoming kylo she becomes
one with the force she scratches his
face and
planet splits in half they get off the
planet starkiller base blows up
and the day is essentially saved and so
they get back
to the resistance kylo ren scurries off
back to the
first order that's not the empire first
order goes back to see the snoke guy
and so they're back at the the
resistance camp right
and so you got you got the little circle
droid
that's not r2d2 but he finds r2d2
and rct2 wakes up and it turns out
r2d2 he's got the other piece of the map
he's got the other piece of the map
because the
the the circle droid only had a little
piece but r2d2 has got the rest of it
and so i don't know why r2d2 has it
i don't know if that's explained or not
but anyway
he does so they put him together and
then they know where luke skywalker is
and they can find luke skywalker
and so kylo ren goes off to
quote-unquote complete the rest of his
training
according to the snoke guy and rey goes
off on her own little quest
almost like luke skywalker going off to
dagobah
um in the beginning of empire strikes
back she goes on her own little quest to
find luke skywalker she goes into that
system
and she goes to this beautiful looking
planet and they're playing this
beautiful music and she finds him
she walks up to him and there's luke
much older and she
reaches out the lightsaber and she's
like hey take take it and we'll see what
happens
and that's how the movie ended alright
so that was kind of my synopsis
of the force awakens so did i enjoy the
movie
yes this movie was fun did i enjoy this
movie
more than a new hope yes i absolutely
enjoyed this movie more than a new hope
and i'm sorry i know i know i know
you're upset
i know you're mad but as i said in my
new hope review though i respect that
movie for being the first thing of its
kind that movie is
sloppy it's sloppy and they did not know
what they were doing
this movie is far more cohesive better
put together
they had more of an idea of what themes
they were going for
and it's just more exciting more
visually interesting
and for that reason i personally had
more fun
watching it than i did a new hope but
that's just
my opinion to judge the movie on its own
merits i will say this the criticisms
from the beginning of this video still
stand this movie is basically a repeat
of old beats
it doesn't do anything not safe
it's very sanitized it is back down
nostalgia lane
i think that star wars fans should like
this movie now i know a lot of you don't
like this movie
i'm not exactly sure why i thought the
movie was well done
the greatest movie ever no um but as far
as
star wars movies go i think this is a
solid star wars film
and uh that's pretty much what i got to
say about star wars force awakens now do
i want to watch this movie again do i
need to watch this movie every year
no i pretty much got the gist of it but
it definitely did not make my eyes bleed
and make me want to bash out my own
brains like watching the prequels did
now as for the next two movies in the
trilogy
well i s we got some things to say
and i'll just say that for the next star
wars review
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
also if you haven't yet follow me on
twitter click the link in the
description
please do it click click the link and
also if you want to support this channel
you can click the patreon link
you know right here or you can make a
one-time donation on
paypal which is also like right here
thank you guys so much for watching
peace out
typical begging like the scum he
is the fool keeps me prisoner here but
allows me to access his systems
i have full access to all of his most
private databanks
and i will use this information to aid
in quinn's undoing
little does he know he's already given
me the tools to destroy him
he goes on about cyborgs the butlerian
jihad the merging of mankind and machine
droid writes yet he speaks nothing of my
rights
ah yes here the human anatomy
soon quinn soon you will obey my every
command